India is facing the ballot now you must
be wondering why is this important well
India is the world's largest democracy
it's also projected to become the
world's largest country in terms of
population by 2020 its economy is
projected to grow and become the third
largest economy in the world by 2030 and
to top it up it's a nuclear power now
these are just some few factors that
make it a key player in world politics
now before we go any further let's have
a quick look at the two largest
political leaders the incumbent Prime
Minister Narendra Modi is from the BJP
party a Hindu nationalist party now the
party is pro-business Rahul Gandhi is
the candidate of the Congress party and
the party is socially democratic with
policies such as minimum income for
everyone to get a better picture of this
election I'm now joined by Rajesh Joshi
he's a senior editor at NDTV which is
one of India's largest news networks and
he is also an author you - welcome thank
you very much Bunji cook if I character
correctly pronounce your name yes you
did
how big are these elections see I mean
you know you have to understand you know
the you know India is a vast country
it's the seventh biggest country in
terms of area but it is the second
biggest country in the term in terms of
population so this you will understand
how big is the election if you take the
number of voters who will go out to vote
nine hundred million people will go out
to exercise their right so it makes
around ten times the population of
Germany and it becomes more important
and somewhat difficult for the for the
election machinery because large part of
India is dominated by the insurgents a
beat internal problem with the Maoist
insurgency the left wing acts
or in the bordering areas like Jammu and
Kashmir or in the northeast area where
another times of kind of insurgency is
happening so it's a different kind of
problems with it but it's it's great to
tell you that this has been happening
very successfully for last so many years
and every time you know it would be a
success to conduct the election at such
a phenomenal scale and indeed that the
elections are huge which comes with
implication now India is a nuclear power
and we've seen the country flexing its
military ability with its neighbour
Pakistan how would this election
influence regional relations see you
will have to look it like this
India is a military power and India also
knows that Pakistan is also a military
power you know so in South Asia
you know this balance is there because
of both the countries having the nuclear
warheads no sane mind will try or even
think of exercising this nuclear weapon
so but these are these work as a
deterrent but since India is going you
know for the parliamentary election and
our prime minister you know has taken a
very hard line against Pakistan
definitely this has given a edge to the
ruling party because you know this idea
of you know showing yourself as a
superpower and your military part
definitely clicks with the voters so I
think India has done the airstrike on
Pakistan in in in you know retaliation
of the Jevons those were killed in Jammu
and Kashmir so that is going definitely
going to give an edge to the ruling
party and this can be critical for for
these elections and speaking of the
ruling party the incumbents of Prime
Minister Modi has been promising a lot
let's take a look at his vision
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and some of the things have changed in
his first term in office but
unemployment is still a pressing issue
so how does unemployment in India affect
other countries see if you if you look
at you know India is India is growing
and India is you know India as a large
number of people have come out of
poverty in in in the last 20 30 years
but still it's you know I won't call you
know 30 percent of humanity still lives
below poverty line so and jobs are
really a problem because the resources
are less and the population pressure is
very high so what this what every
government successive moment a you know
they have been during the election
campaigns they have been promising about
job creation and providing jobs but
that's not easy when you come to power
you you you see that this is actually
not easy to do that
so when Narendra Modi the Prime Minister
who has last time was this Challenger he
was challenging the incumbent government
that when he comes to power he will give
phenomenal number of you know jobs every
year and some people say around 10
million jobs some people say 20 million
job every year but you know and now his
critics and the opposition party are
targeting him for not providing those
many jobs however the ruling party
counters it by saying that though they
may not have provided that a job but
they have provided job job opportunities
by by easy loans and you know kind of
different different government schemes
so this kind of you know war of words
happening in India but you know I would
like to tell you some facts recent
reports by National Sample Survey which
is which works under India's Ministry
it's a government you know body each one
of its a report was not published by
government it was suppressed by the
government but it reportedly doubt and
in newspapers it told us that India's
unemployment is highest in last last 45
years so that was a very embarrassing
you know a report for government so the
the problem of unemployment is there
whoever comes to power
Narendra Modi the present Prime Minister
and his party passage in the party BJP
if it repeats or the challenging
principal opposition parties they come
to power job creation will be will
remain a problem for them
and why the main opposition Congress
party has proposed a basic income of
1046 a US Dollars and you're saying job
creation is already a problem so how can
they be able to accomplish this huge
task and I told you the large number of
people in India they live below poverty
line
they cannot you know you you can't leave
them like that so in 2004 also when
Congress party which is now in
opposition when it was trying to come
back to father they promised one hundred
days employment to every rural one
person at least from every rural
household so Rahul Adi who is the same
from the same political party now
heading the party he has taken the same
line same socialist line saying that now
I will give you the income minimum
income because he know that there is
farm distress farmers are in problem the
the labourers are in problem you know
people who live you know who are poor
who live below poverty line they are
really toiling very hard so what he is
trying to say that I will give you
relief please what for us India's carbon
emissions have increased tremendously in
1960 we started at 121 a thousand kilo
tons in 1980 it nearly tripled in 2000
it reached 1 million kilo tons and in
2014 it's more than doubled what is the
stand of the two biggest parties on
climate change we are the victims of
climate so both the parties are
recognizing it but they are not
discussing it as much as they should but
one thing I would say India has taken
some steps and promised the world that
we will we will take steps we will we
will plant forests off to sequester
carbon around 2.5 to 3 billion tons of
carbon in till 2030
we are going to increase our clean
energy to one point 175 gigawatts
we are also cutting our urban emission
by 2030 to carbon emission intensity
actually I would say 30 to 33 percent 33
to 35 percent so these are the steps
which give you hope thank you so so much
every day as joshi for your time thank
you very much for your nice to be here
if you wish to see more videos like this
one make sure you subscribe until next
time goodbye